our number three doesn't show on the
arrow in a good time because well when
you show up early and we love hanging
out and you want to hang out you join us
here in studio our number three we've
been already having Jerome Bettis and
Tom Verducci on and on phone but I turn
to my right and welcome back in person
from the Rich Eisen shows past now
current present the fighter and the kid
podcast would Brendan Schaub is what
he's been on talking about quite a bit
but he's an ABC schooled second season
schooled the Goldberg spin-off comedy
set in the 90s Wednesdays at 8:30 p.m.
7:30 central on ABC good to see you back
Bryan Callen here my friend I'm wearing
a collared shirt in honor just out of
respect respect worked out yesterday so
I'm a little sore I had my trainer at
the trainer cuz you got to have a
trainer in LA he had me flipping a tire
just in case I'm ever in situation I
feel like like somebody is holding my
cheeks well I I can't right now you know
a whole area that gets very sore yeah so
I'm feeling a little sense it a little
tender well you're nothing changes I
work out I just feel sore but nothing
gross I uh here's here's where I'm
coming from
um I didn't have a tire I mean what do
you know what sort of but but yeah you
have an amazing body you guys haven't
seen him standing up you know I got in
person I miss arresting you you
shouldn't by the way yeah and I don't
use the word arresting thank you thank
you
what was this was this a what type of
tire was this was a tractor tire so it
wasn't like a donut but do I look like
have you seen my lower body I'm gonna
I'm wearing tights underneath this but
here's the thing yes
you got it yeah and then they said keep
your back straight you gotta get your
load I'm 52 I'm 50
I laid tennis for an hour yesterday what
that is serious workout man do you play
tennis I'm I'm I'm learning it dude I'm
with you can't play with you my I mean
my topspin I mean if you have you're a
beginner you got to be somewhere in
Kentucky to return my topspin okay yeah
I come up hey this is the noise I made
not to be obnoxious tone what
it's that right - a little worm look at
my where my elbow is that's how I end
that's okay I know it is do you grunt
and yell like that when you hit bro I
have to I'm but I'm putting my pear hold
on I stand up my whole body I come off
yeah I come off the granite hole like my
job
you're like Nadal you're all little
slice yeah I slice it so you're you're
like I gotta go all the way back here
and get ducky and then come back home
it's too late you can't run my serve is
gender neutral I can't sweaty oh my gosh
see your flip receipt that hurt my body
you see you're flipping tires you're
slicing your your your the top spinning
your [ __ ] your tops many slicing into
its flipping tires she's a couple you
apply yourself I'm still I'm still I'm
still learning how to brush I'm still
learning how to brush easy it's all
fundamentals it's funny by the way did
you see how I move my hand well we had
Timothy Olyphant
on back in was it March he's a serious
tennis player so I used my arm to show
how I hit the backhand and I came
forward with my hand just like a like I
was slapping a wall yeah he just stopped
me dead in my tracks and just [ __ ] me
Tori knew it now I'm now I'm brushing
what I'm saying I'm coming over I'm
brushing but I'm not I'm not screaming
maybe I need to add the grunt into my
game he'll take my workshop and we'll go
from there it's fifty six hundred
dollars for the weekend well I heard
that in a doll yes after he won
Wimbledon I don't know if this is true
but I heard he was my friends in the
game you know he was he plays and he
said any I guess he knows I mean he said
when the dog came back he'd won they
were like I think I know but I'm just my
grip I feel like I should be more over
he was still tweaking his grip it's it
those little details maybe I should
start tweaking my grip we'll talk about
it
Bryan Callen you're great bro you got
update over there the bronze I gotta say
lots of fun stuff
Foxborough authorities say a Rhode
Island man visiting the Patriots Hall of
Fame took a Tom Brady Jersey off display
and walked out with it what I'm outraged
I'm outraged we had it was free personal
recognizance after not guilty plea no
larceny was entered on behalf think it
was just for sale and he just told me
yes he said was a jersey under his
jacket when he was apprehended in the
vicinity of the Hall of Fame the signed
jersey what's with blazing in jerseys
just going walking personal Locker from
his own Super Bowl locker from his own
Pro Hall of Fame everyone thinks he's
not gonna be on the team next year so
this is trying to grab as much
memorabilia as we can from Tom I
understand the temptation I mean you
know it is Brady it's a piece of history
I was in a store recently where an older
man was talking and I just watched him
very deliberately grab some candy and
just put him into pocket he just went
like that and put it in his pocket and I
just watched this thief this thief and
and then he said what's over there and
he did it again and I went I should I
say something and I was like you know
what though you're a thousand years old
ahead with yourself exactly
I'm a certain at certain point I mean
the five things out of some candy in an
in a store the candy hard candy of
course you know that's get away your
dentures yeah and then I robbed him of
his candy when he got out of the store a
childhood memory of mine and my mom
watches every day her dad my grandpa Leo
always had hard candy in his pocket and
he would just sometimes take out just
give it to me in the middle of nowhere I
stole an orange from a fruit stand yeah
when I was a very small boy and I
remember my mother making me go back to
the guy and telling him that I stolen
orange this this is a kid I remember
going I took an orange this sounds like
a Coppola movie right there I know
listen that was my life that was my life
in crime that's how we start
I just watch the the to our interview
with Sammy the bull Gravano made me like
the guy killed 19 19 who cares he killed
two people I think we I went to grade
school with one of his family members oh
really oh yeah we all knew ya grew up in
Staten Island yeah couple guys couple of
cuties make sure yeah make sure hey
somebody wants a juice box you
understand what happened with Nick Saban
yes yes let's let's hear from Nick Saban
so of course two is out this week yes so
they're starting a sophomore quarterback
but to his younger brother
tolya tag a viola is on the roster and
he was asked they've taken on two and
five Arkansas Arkansas is just not
nearly as good as they've ever since be
lamella right beyond the Patriots that
so there he was asked if if to his
brother is gonna get any time is this an
opportunity to kind of see what you got
with this kid and to get him in the game
and get some rest because just in front
of this if you say that to Nick that
means you're assuming the competition is
so beneath Alabama right that you're
going to use a home game against
Arkansas like it's a spring practice
like it's a practice I got to scrimmage
a time to get some reps so oh no here's
Nick Saban oh no will there be an effort
to get Talia into the game just to
expedite his uh-oh his progression no
we're focused on winning the game
alright so we're gonna try to win the
game we're gonna play the best players
that we can play to win the game oh no
and we're not assuming that it's gonna
be an easy game look out I and we're not
assuming that we'll have opportunity
this to play anybody that wants to play
expedite anything except winning the
game so we're gonna play everybody who
can expedite winning the game that's
what that's what we're gonna do so I
don't think anybody should expect us to
do anything else
I love bottom line guys
yes bottom line no nonsense
we need more of that I love it because I
mean again the premise of the question
is like so great question though just
assume you're gonna beat Arkansas's ass
up and down the block so why don't you
just use some of this free time to get
in some extra work for players who are
third on the depth chart what do you
think exact show some promise there's
sorts thing like is that the plan so for
him to basically say yeah
yeah that's the plan we plan on beating
Arkansas yeah what I do think that
there's a I do think that if you've got
a team you can march over and you got
your starters you would do well to rest
them and not risk injury I've always
said that if you look at teams I've
never done the math on this but there
are I think there are a lot of teams
that if their defense is injured there
are their stars like their defensive
line a lot of Myr injured in the
beginning of the season and they have
time to rest and then they come in Game
six they're in a better position by the
time I mean but savings from the
Belichick mold I mean that's literally
where he came from he was on the staff
right as Bella checks on the verge of
his 30 hunt 300th career win he was on
the staff I think when when Bill got his
first I assume I think he was an
assistant right from the get-go in
Cleveland for for Belichick I'm not sure
at any isabela check guy bill kept Brady
and the entire offense starting offense
on the field against the Jets on Monday
night all the way to the end because it
and it's not part of the plan going in
but when it does happen when it breaks
out like that they've you bill and Brady
view those moments as crucial reps to
get better I guess so I you just risk
injury if you're belcheck you could
basically fill the slot with a high
school player and you're still gonna win
that guy's just unbelievable he's just a
genius so it feels like he doesn't need
anybody trades Randy Moss don't worry
about it we'll get somebody else getting
some Irish guy
I mean that's Belichick so I guess bad
for me the philosophy would be your
precious stay on sideline we don't want
to get you injured let's talk a little
UFC with with the Melissa he has a
announced his fight it's gonna fight
next year early January 2020 no opponent
but it will but it will be in Las Vegas
we have some sound from Connor here we
go okay let's check out I would like to
announce to the public the return of the
notorious Conor McGregor will take place
on January 18th in the t-mobile Arena in
Las Vegas Nevada so that is my comeback
fight it is 12 weeks this Saturday I'm
in prime physical condition I have
agreed the date with the apart I've
agreed the date with the company as far
as the opponent I have the opponent's
name but for me I became I am in and
from experience if I was to give you
people the name which I would love to do
I know the UFC would flip it because
there they are a crafty company so for
me here's this one ask the UFC who the
opponent is because I do not give a 3d
apologies
January 18th the return of the notorious
Conor McGregor 12 weeks this Saturday at
the t-mobile Arena in Las Vegas Nevada
that will be the beginning of my season
I will then look to compete against the
winner of Nate Diaz
Jorge massive results for the five
mother title obviously I have history
with Nate Diaz we are set to make the
trilogy belt so we will see how that one
goes I still may look at the better of
that one and we will contest the trilogy
belt then I will seek the Moscow bout
and it will be against the winner of
Tony Ferguson and khabib nurmagomedov I
can't even say the guy's name who cos of
the damage but that is about we want we
want this belt in Moscow
the people of Russia deserve this bout
to take place the people of the world
deserve this bout to take place it is an
inevitable rematch it is a rematch that
I will come in sharp flesh I will have
no injuries I will have no alcohol I
will have no outside influences I will
be fully focused exactly what the people
deserve exactly what the fans deserve
and we will settle it once and for all
everybody calm down just calm down he
doesn't want any part of khabib
nurmagomedov all right he's just the guy
is a problem you can't solve I don't
know what you do with that wrestling
could be walks around at 200 and 200
pounds he's just he's a bear
he's wrestled them he's he just he does
whatever he wants to you he just locks
your legs up like this he locks him up
and now you're like this yeah like all
my wrestling is gone then he just slams
it out I think he can't I don't want to
see him do that I want to see him I love
his attitude I think he's great for the
UFC I want to see him fight somebody he
can stand with not wrestle so there's a
lot to unpack with what we just heard
Brian yeah let's start with first the
first things first radio audience you
didn't see the only way I could describe
his look to use I guess a Vegas
pop-culture references Matt Damon in
Ocean's eleven the way that he at the
very end where he played somebody who is
from the Vegas Authority you know the
hair very neatly slicked back what what
what what's that look he's always
dressed to a tee we had him on fighter
in a kid and he just showed up in in the
tightest white pants and this this
fantastic watch he just he sparkles the
man sparkles he's a star but Matt Damon
is you know what I can never get over
with that guy I love him as an actor I
love him yeah in the fighting was the
first Shaq Ryan or whatever was when
he's running down the beach hmm and do
you remember this and he was a boy
kicking his legs way too high and I
swear to God in the middle I'm with my
friend in the middle of them in the
middle of the theater I go guys never
done a sport my friend goes I agree
I can't abide by the fact you're running
your high tailing like that you got it
I don't know there's a way to run for
you you can't run like that then I got
it I got to see your passport you're an
American but the glasses right there I
mean that was Lex well I'm sure those
glasses don't work but there's something
real no but you look you know if you're
muscular and you have glasses it's a
wonderful contrast for you and McGregor
look that he's got working right you
know like that's enough I mean that's
the way his birth that's way he's
looking right there so there's that Nate
Diaz just tapped out of 244 so what's he
talking about with Nate
I believe that Nate will be exonerated
okay I believe that Nate Diaz is too
macho to do any kind of a
performance-enhancing drug I'm serious
that guy look at you and be like I'll
fight him wake me up from a nap I don't
even have to train I just don't buy but
these tests what was his name
send oh it's a what's his name the guy
who they call him the Golden Snitch
the guy who runs you sada good guy
actually but he was saying that these
tests are so sensitive now they pick up
on anything it's like a seismograph
there's any little like you know
elevated levels so you know yeah a
little bit levels of what I'm not buying
it I usually would be like yes he's
dirty
I'm saying Nate Diaz is clean I put all
my money on it there's no way so he is
maybe he drank of some kind of a maybe
he took a certain like maybe a gasoline
station sex pill he's innocent he's
innocent
I say Nate Diaz is innocent fine Jorge
miles Randolph
those are two of my favorite fighters
the Diaz brothers and were hey Maz Badal
hmm I mean every man when you see her I
hope the way he wants to fight so badly
I produce estrogen around that guy I
watch it and I'm just like I'll cook
what are you I've elevated levels on the
whole time I'm looking at him oh my god
I thought I was straight this whole time
I'm so confused come on Jorge miles
Vidal Nate Diaz I'd love to throw connor
into that mix but I say against Jorge
Moz Vidal yeah Connor doesn't want that
fight I mean he wants it but I don't
think so fight this Connor really want I
think you got to give Connor
somebody who's strictly a striker I
don't know that if Tony Ferguson these
people are monsters they live and
breathe it you know Connor is a true
fighter but he's so wealthy he's such a
celebrity I don't know how you compete
with that girl why doesn't you want to
go and just be so low because he's a
fighter and in his heart he's you don't
get too
where he got without being a savage I
just think though that there's some
people that are imparted that puzzle the
stuff they do the way they live and
breathe fighting their ingenuity it's
very hard to deal with I remember a lot
of the guys that Connor starched was at
forty five when he was here he was a big
45 and his boxing was high level in
comparison those guys right he'd stay on
the end and the edge of the pocket he
understood distance he had longer arms
he'd hit you and you go to sleep then he
started fighting guys who are bigger
well ice when I knew when he when he
fought and eight Diaz the first fight I
went I've never seen Nate get hurt I've
never seen him get dropped really I've
seen him get picked up and slammed to
the ground but never I didn't think he
had the power and that's exactly what
happened so I don't know man at 55 at 55
Connors natural weight is 170 170 that's
his frame cubby walks at 195 ask-ask
Dustin Poirier about that Dustin's a
beast and it just it's just sometimes
you're just too strong coming here
that's what he does egg come on that's
hilarious that's adorable let me just
let me just put your jaw in your neck be
come on what he was beating up who was
it Michael uh Johnson he was gonna come
on buddy that buddy do you know the belt
is mine Bobby fast come on he's beating
him up come on I don't want to hurt you
when you're going come on man tap I want
to keep doing this to your nose
I mean that's I'm getting sweaty accent
my apologies by the way it's not but I
mean you do this for a living
I've heard your accent what's your best
accent probably um if I was if I were to
play someone who's from England I've
always wanted to be I've always wanted
to be someone who's an aristocrat I want
to be an evil aristocrat I want to say
things I want to own land and hounds and
I want to say things like release the
hounds and I want to have a dungeon
where I keep people and I want to come
down and say you know they keep you in a
dungeon English aristocrats and in your
chained to a wall and that you still
want to marry them just because the way
they apologize you don't I mean they
come down they go I do apologize for
your other restrictive accommodation was
unavoidable I'd hoped we'd be friends
but alas you wouldn't cooperate yes your
silence is to be expected I know you
think of me as some kind of monster and
I will not deny that sin is my
speciality deception the thievery and
even perversion rich and a cane i went
in england with my friend are made a
billion dollars and okay I had to wear I
had to wear like knickers and tie sure
and the guy was the one dude showed up
in a cane didn't need it with it I I'm
not with an ascot and they're all
alcoholics just drinking they're all 35
he's got an ascot it was incredible we
shot we killed all the thousand
pheasants we killed all of them they
flushed them with birds you have a
loader a dude who those is he's go easy
he's not he's not posh no he's got a
sort of cockney and he [ __ ] my I didn't
have to [ __ ] my or load my shotgun I go
load please ain't loaded and then they
the birds of fire head and I just I just
at first I was like I don't want to kill
them and about five minutes later I was
like die
you know anything automatic you have an
automatic weapon I killed everything
everything that flew so there it is it's
funny we had Tyson Fury on here Bryan
Callen on the Richards your life
we had Tyson Fury hear about was about
two three months ago when he came in
here right yeah okay and I went back
there's always always like going back to
our green room when a guest is here
before and I walked in and it was
literally like a Guy Ritchie movie you
know in a dream room yeah okay yeah
we're gypsies we're we're all of its
right all of his all of his friends were
there and just saying how you know
they're excited to be here and just
talking about and I'm assuming that's
where they're saying I didn't understand
I'm seriously I did not understand a
word they said that cockney Ron I mean
just old and they were like he's got
that really honestly I thought this is
gonna be a fascinating conversation only
because I'm of just a fan of his story
and his and and and everything's about
him right and I would just wanted to
delve into it but get to some of the
more interesting parts in the most
ginger fashion I possibly could get in
and out and then just but I've left them
I came out here and I said to you I said
oh my god I don't know if I'm going to
understand a word that they're going to
say his cut man was doing magic tricks
yeah that's right he was dressed he was
dressed like Conor McGregor like to the
nines
Wow like it was you walk into your own
green room and they we never see you
again
and you're just living in his coat
somewhere somewhere in his problem he's
right here and they pick my Ridge his
name is rich you can play with him for a
while give him back to his line there
right there dressed in this breaking ham
and he had these these these John
Stockton shorts they're very short which
by the way down would come down to my
shin yes on here
that's the thing about photography you
look like you're actually bigger than
Titan the optical illusion doesn't throw
you around like a baton if you wanted he
he was just kind of slumped in the chair
and his legs came all the way halfway to
my desk and it was wild I didn't at one
point like you know I asked him about
you know against Wilder and what
happened and he talked about how he he
got up and I'm like well some people
would think that you know you got kind
of more than 10 seconds kill 11 seconds
and then he just gave me this look and
then went off on this amazing soliloquy
where he answered the question and well
what would you say to something like
what would people say if I told them
about you know driving down a road or a
hundred miles an hour and you know
staring into the abyss
you know I'm paraphrasing basically like
staring into the abyss and thinking
about death and all I'm like oh my gosh
and then again I'm thinking is he saying
this number one in - am i understanding
everything that's coming out of his
mouth that's when you're listening super
hard please don't want to make a mad oh
god no you know oh god no
yeah yeah it's never happen
tell me about schooled sir it looks like
you're having a lot of fun on this last
Tim Meadows come on Tim Meadows right
the ana gasteyer all this Saturday Night
Live alum it's it's it's look you when
you're an actor as long as I've been
doing this game you a lot of times you
get hired you're on the set without
exception including the Joker including
The Hangover whatever movie it might be
that's big you're always allowed to
improvise you're allowed to add some
stuff and then you do the Goldbergs for
as long as I did and I'm now I'm doing
skooled the writing to me is I don't
need ya I don't have to fill in any gaps
they do the work for you so I just show
up hang out with a bunch of people I
like and then I do stuff like that and
I'm an act like a silly goose and it's
it's it's another hit for this series
and oh my gosh I know I finally did it
yeah I've been doing it for it I hit one
it's like you just keep swinging at
every pitch well you mentioned you
mentioned a couple movies of your and
obviously Joker hangover what was it
like on the set of Bad Santa what was it
like there uh by the way same writer
actor as the Joker a lot of people are
real no no those names on the page one
rewrite and directed it
that was a Billy Bob Thornton's just a
great dude he's just a great guy and
watching that guy improvise that's
another guy who would just do a
different take every time you didn't
know what was gonna go on yeah I wanted
to do his own stunts play was a baseball
player himself an athlete so you know I
don't know the whole thing was anytime
you're working with people like that
it's just exciting I'm just happy to be
there the acting gets in the way I love
it good to see you Bryan Callen at Bryan
Callen on both Twitter and Instagram
check out again the fighter in the kid
podcast a number of times I have said to
you and Brendan on this show that I
would come on your show
standing invites I know you keep saying
that and doesn't fan it does not it does
not you know I would love it I would
absolutely love it a check out schooled
on ABC Wednesdays at 8:30 p.m. 7:30
central every single Wednesday for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app